hello
everyone i hope you all are doing great
and enjoying your learning process
and either working on the project or
finished your research project
this video is to guide you towards your
project submission on the learn portal
to begin with ensure that your profile
is complete
that is you have an updated profile
picture and also linked in your social
accounts
i would be taking an example of one of
our research fellows
singh who has completed her profile with
a profile picture
linked in her linkedin account so that
we can feature her progress on
our socials and tag her and also as you
can see that in the profile
section itself we can see what all
courses has she covered
and her project submission as well so we
can see here that she has completed
a few of the courses and she can view
her certificate
in the certificate tab under her profile
section
only and download her certificate for
sure
to submit your project on the learn
portal you need to have
a score of 10 000 and only then you
would
be eligible to upload your project
on the learn portal in the profile
section itself you have a section called
projects here you have to submit the
project now let me quickly take you
through how you have to submit the
project
so what you have to do is you have to
create a presentation first of all
and record your presentation and after
recording your presentation
share the mp4 file with me i'll upload
it on a youtube channel
and share the embed code with you to
upload it
on your project section in the profile
tab
so here we begin with the steps overview
data sets abstract and so on i'll take
on one step one time
so in the overview section you have to
first of all get the title of your
project
and upload or say put in the embed code
which i would be sharing with you
and then comes the data sets part where
you have to upload
the data sets which you used for your
analysis
and the data sets have to be uploaded on
data warts
i would be again sharing a video with
you on how you can upload your data set
on database
and share the link here and then you
have to give
an abstract for your project and then
write the introduction
introduction would have an overview of
what you worked on
and also the images have to be uh
attached here with the introduction part
in the methods part you need to mention
the methodology that was used to carry
out the analysis
in your research project as you can see
akansha has also
uh used the images of a pipeline which
she
run to carry out her analysis and then
finally comes a results tab where you
have to
tell what results you obtained
also use the images upload the images
your scatter plots or whatever plots you
worked on and
uh got for your project
and then finally comes the discussion
tab
in the discussion tab you have to
mention what you
uh finally got from your result and
conclude your project
and don't forget to mention the
references because that's really
very important and finally comes the
acknowledgement time where you have to
give
acknowledgement to your mentor and
whatever support you got
throughout your project so that is the
easiest way of uploading your project
on the learn portal and once you upload
your project on the learn portal
you would be uh your project would be
visible
to all of the people on the learn portal
as you
as you can see that we already have a
lot of submissions of projects by now
and the submissions are there on the
portal and you can
also go through each and every project
and get an idea
of how our research fellows worked on
different sorts of analysis
and got the results for your reference
i'll share the link
of the projects part on the portal
in the comments section in the
description
of the video looking forward to your
project submission